so um I talk a lot about the women that
are aged maybe 40 to 60. that really
just raised like the worst generation of
women ever they did I mean they did not
teach us how to be wives most of them
don't believe in submitting to their
husbands Authority most of them are
overweight and most of them really have
issues and you know I mean most people
have issues my generation is no better
but
I'll tell you I call them the generation
of shitty wives for a reason so Jeannie
Mae and Jeezy
um actually were married about two years
ago now now Jeannie Mae has historically
never wanted children and she was
married to another guy for about 10
years
um and she was married to another guy
for 10 years and did not want kids with
him then you know she gets engaged and
marries a world Superstar and magically
she wants children how how crazy is that
but they did get married and honestly
guys they I thought they were such a
cute couple I mean Genie went on TV and
talked about she wanted to submit to his
authority but in my opinion it sort of
looks like her anger issues that she's
admitted to really have gotten the best
of her so let's pull the clip it's over
Virginia Mai and Jeezy the TV
personality and the rapper are divorcing
two years after saying I do Access
Hollywood has learned according to legal
documents obtained by NBC News gz filed
paperwork on September 14th to end his
ingenious marriage and is requesting
joint custody of their 20-month-old
daughter Monaco a prenup is in place
access has reached out to both parties
for comment the couple tied the knot in
March 2021 in an intimate ceremony at
their Georgia home and Jeannie
previously explained how pandemic
restrictions and personal loss shifted
their original plan to Wed in the south
of France telling Vogue at the time
after Jeezy's mother unexpectedly passed
we quickly learned that life is too
short and at the end of the day Jeezy
and I really just wanted to become
husband and wife so we decided to turn
our original wedding into a mini-money
where we exchanged our vows in front of
our immediate family and a few close
friends I have a really hot temper not a
lot of people know this but it's just
something in my family I've seen it my
grandmother I'm sorry I saw it in my
grandfather to my grandmother to my mom
to my aunts to me right but I didn't
notice it in myself until I was with
Jeezy interesting you notice in your
previous marriage no no because I
because
it has to do with the type of
relationship you have and the type of
respect you have for that person to
mirror things back to you where you
actually would stop you in your tracks
end
evaluate yourself you know so you had it
so I had it but nobody ever nobody ever
called me out on it also in my line of
work sometimes being a boss isn't so
isn't so great for you because you have
a lot of people who just agree to what
you want they're Yes Men right and so I
didn't notice that I had a hot temper
until I got with Jeezy yeah so here
Jeannie is talking about how you know
she's never been checked on anger her
anger her temper before and as women do
we blame the we take the accountability
and put it on the family whatever and
you know with a guy like Jeezy who has
all the leverage this shit's just not
gonna fly it's not gonna work and
um unfortunately this is why guys like
younger women you know I mean what are
her odds of changing a habit she's had
for uh 40 years
I mean guys that's a long time the
second thing was they met in covid and I
just think a lot of people that had
their relationships start in covid I
just don't really see lasting for the
Long Haul so Jeannie um posted on
Instagram she said today I celebrate a
remarkable Milestone achieved by my
husband Jeezy whose Memoir adversity for
sale has soared to the New York Times
bestsellers list your story has always
been an inspiration to me but seeing it
in print has left me even more in awe of
your strength and wisdom you invited us
into the most intimate corners of your
life where pain and Triumph coexist this
moment isn't just a testament to your
literary skills baby but a recognition
of your ability to inspire through the
power of Storytelling I'm endlessly
grateful for your voice in the world
honored to walk beside you love and you
can see in the comments section anavona
says this is so odd how she posted this
a week ago and then he files commented
on here with the heart damn Genie I'm
sorry and you know Jesus is kind of a
Savage I gotta be honest guys he posts
this I'm too focused on who I'm becoming
to focus on who's not coming with me
yeah guys so I just I I think it goes to
show this is why guys kind of tend to
pick younger chicks I mean uh at 40 a
woman that has never really wanted kids
isn't really gonna have the motherly
instincts you're looking for and not and
I mean let's just be honest guys I don't
know if really world-renowned Superstars
typically make the best husbands I don't
know if they're all meant for like a
more traditional life so it'll be
interesting to see how this plays out
um see he had a prenup which is a good
thing we're pro prenups here yeah and
this is really a lesson to the younger
women that if you have anger issues that
shit's not gonna fly you can't you can
only get away with that with a guy you
don't respect and and you see Jeannie
divorced her first husband it was a guy
that never checked her and then she got
divorced but I got that checked here
probably because she couldn't handle her
anchor issues but let me know in the
comments on what you guys think uh make
sure you like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time